you
hello and welcome to la vie gamespot's
weekly hang it every tuesday at 2pm
specifically pacific right here on
gamespot com I'm your host Daniel are
hating folks what's going on video games
are happening Justin hey walls here
alexa ray korea's here but we're going
to talk first of all not necessarily
their video games kind of video games
kind of about Star Wars kind of at
Disney what the hell's going on d23 was
on over the weekend my twitter feed was
just like a bunch of weird [ __ ] all
happening at the same time yeah i was at
d23 it's like the biannual disney expo
and because we have a lot of Marvel in
Star Wars things happening this year
there was a big star wars exhibit big
Marvel exhibits a lot of news came out
of that we saw trailers for Doctor
Strange and which hasn't started filming
yet but we have footage hi and then
captain america civil war yeah right any
strange dr. strange it's still it's
still hard for me to wrap my head around
that Disney isn't it's not just a house
of the mouse it's the house of Star Wars
and House of Marvel and lighten which is
so when are they just gonna by Nintendo
that's next payday so let's start we'll
dive into all the different bits and
bobs that you saw when you were there in
a second but like what to justins point
what's the vibe like there because we go
to something like III and it's like oh
well here for video games or you go to
like you know comic-con it's kind of
like oh we're all here for like comics I
kind of movies as well whereas this is
like there's so many pies it's touching
it's like everything from toys to live
video games to like Star Wars stuff too
like crazy vintage Disney's oh yeah
what's it like there so number one the
bar to get in is very high the tickets
are like two hundred dollars Wow and
there it's a three-day event it was it
smelled wonderful and it was different
it was not crowded like I so they had on
display the new storm troopers from the
force awakens they had captain phasma
czar murs set up like for you and then
they had like a display with ray infants
costumes and one of the bb-8 props cool
that's a little Bowl thing right oh no
he's this big alright reallys like this
babe was he like did you get to see him
move like his he's a practical effect
that he yeah actually moves around on
see did you get to like see him in
action I didn't get to see move but I
touched him and someone yelled at me and
I am NOT and when he turned around I
touched him again yeah um but uh the
leak rolling away the exhibits were
roped off but you could get right
to the edge of that exhibit like it
wasn't crowded people weren't like
smashed around it it was just people
taking photos moving on how many people
Rob base let them feel like oh my god
it's hard to tell you on a scale of like
12 san diego comic-con it was maybe like
a four look we're not crowded at all
there was space like I was never caught
in a crowd there's a letter to move did
you think you up for stuff like get in
line yes their work they were lying
there were lines to buy things like that
okay to Disney specific stores with
exclusive merchandise and art stuff and
the lines for those are maybe like an
hour long all the collectors are going
to be disney has been done science I
mean not just with the number of races
that they do that sell out almost
immediately now every year but all the
different pens now all the merchandise
related to start already pens pens
t-shirt people people line up they will
go to these events just to get a pen
just to get this special shirt that says
I was Disney at star wars on 2014 august
fourteenth and then load you know do a
different shirt for the next day yep and
they're so good at like like this is in
a bizarre way i'd like to logistics like
one of the best things about going to
disney world is like going to the car
park and seeing how well d just how well
they have that dangerous science and I'm
so happy to work there like even the
people who is just like I'm gonna give
you a hot dog he's smiling yeah I'm
happy to be weird so nice to see the
attendance that were shops it up and
there are people you know did forcers or
whatever and everyone's just so nice I
get bumped and people be like I'm so
sorry but some of the best cosplay I've
ever seen like it was just the whole
vibe was just magical and awesome there
were a lot of kids hmm the kids were
always friendly kind of thing yeah it's
a very very friendly family-friendly
convention their big exhibit this year
was they were previewing that new avatar
films they had like variants okay look I
don't you forgot like yo own avatar sure
yeah avatar and then they had a big
setup detailing the building plans for a
Disneyland Shanghai which looks like
it's gonna be gonna be so they have a
whole Tron ride with the light cycles
and everything that they're building
avoid them yeah like I think that's what
it is and then there's a like a toy
story themed hotel will it be as good as
the knockoff world of warcraft just on
the power theme parkinson china I've
ever seen that right it's awful yeah
there's a fake world of warcraft like
that it's a total ripoff it is a world
of warcraft theme park but not
officially everything
what name where is it it's in somewhere
in China yeah oh girl where we should go
that'd be pretty good I was to be so
cynical about Disney and the things they
did especially when I was younger but
now I'm like as I get older I'm more I
like I found it even more endearing and
I'm like I love going to Disney now it's
like it is literally a magical
experience did you see Angelina Jolie
while you were there no I didn't but I
was about 10 feet away from Daisy Ridley
and John boyega okay Rey and Finn in the
new Star Wars movie I saw them on the
stage for disney infinity which has a
new force awakens force we can set yeah
that's about that they're doing they
only showed a brief clip they showed a
rayon Finn I love I was talking to John
VIN yaki who's mr. infinity and he said
that they showed Daisy Ridley her her
figure and she just like was so ecstatic
and she the one thing that she said was
all you got my shoulders right like they
do they do those figures so well and
they look exactly like them but they
have the force awakens playset I did get
a chance to play the rise against the
Empire and twilight of the Republic I
think it's think they're called the to
the prequel trilogy and the original
Star Wars trilogy sets and I have high
hopes for the force awakens set from
what I played like there are a lot of
fun it's very much wish fulfillment I
drove the Millennium Falcon into the
Death Star and blood of it and there was
like this sequence where you have to
maneuver to get out and his explosions
everything it's the only game they're
the figures right now um this is the
only game where you can beat up Darth
Maul with Olaf the snowman hahaha which
kind of something that one of Johnny's
lines no it doesn't what a monster I'm
like really really really really looking
forward to playing it and I like it and
I played you know some of battlefront at
events and whatnot but I would've about
disney infinity is it's just like that
sense of wonder and that sense of like
you can do anything I played his Boba
Fett and took down in 8018 you can just
do whatever you want it's great i love
it that's excellent are there last bits
and bobs that you like to mention from
will get the kingdom hearts in our
second but apart from that any other
little bits and bobs you saw that like
kind of stuck at two things things you
like to bed d23 that you probably like
to see likes a video game shows that we
get to go to all the time it was so well
organized and people were so just
positive and everyone was just kind like
I'd really like
I don't know I'd love to see these
events where everyone is I feel like
everyone at d23 like there was this big
dynnys disney interactive panel right on
Sunday morning and everyone got like
this exclusive like Kingdom Hearts
Mickey costume for disney infinity and
of course a lot of people go to that
panel just get like the exclusive thing
and like the free stuff or whatever but
everyone who was there like the energy
in the room and the energy when we were
leaving and sort of that whole mess of
cons when you're getting in and out of
big rooms everyone was just really
respectful and really happy and everyone
was there because they wanted to be
there and no one was really like crappy
yeah and I would love to see that
everywhere do you know what this
actually reminds me of is when we went
to blizzcon last year as I was blown
away by how it felt totally different to
a gamescom or an e three threes kind of
it zombies and even a pax were like
people were kind of rushing around to
see everything at pax and I gamescom
it's very much like a getting early
trying to see as much as you can get to
the lines quick whereas when we went to
blizzcon it felt like it was just like a
party everyone got to go to the talks
they wanted to go to and then the lines
weren't that long either well it's also
helped by not having attended everything
I blizzcon is going to be a very focused
event on play games and disney even as
much as there are so many different
things there's enough for everybody to
see all these and there were some
announcements we got to see the new
console and things like that but
otherwise yeah like you get to everyone
gets to be a part of those things where
isn't an e3 or a pax like this is your
first chance to see a lot of stuff and
so Leo you're going to be in a rush
because otherwise you're gonna be in
line for four hours yeah for sure and
speaking of big collaborative exercises
at d23 we also saw as some king well I'm
not sure how much we saw but we saw that
come part three is going to be set in
the grow six yeah there's the world san
fran Tokyo in France Tokyo so cure can
never get that rise do ok I got ya i
feel like a shell for disney though ya
know San fransokyo don't you know all
about the QQ movie um it's uh that was
being in that room was phenomenal they
opened the show with Kingdom Hearts
something about kingdom hearts and
Disney Disney for the past like 10 years
the kingdom hearts is 10 years old more
taken wow I know I'm just gonna by
square enix now but you know what like
yeah
could work Disney Interactive actually
gets the final say for all of Kingdom
Hearts 3 which is weird because Disney
never really acknowledged like Kingdom
Hearts was kind of like the redheaded
stepchild that they gave away pond birth
and sent it to the to the orphanage or
whatever um because they didn't really
they're like oh it's a thing using her
properties were not really it's not
really thing we talked about
uncomfortable but it kind of is no again
yeah I had friends who would visit
visited disneyland disney world in the
past cosplay does kingdom hearts
characters i got kicked out of the park
because they were like that's yeah he
can't see oh my god there was this weird
like disney's relationship with kingdom
hearts has always been like yaoi it
exists and we're just not going to talk
about it yeah disney has with kingdom
hearts 110 percent embraced it and like
now that i think now they're
acknowledging okay kingdom hearts is
super popular it's reinvigorating our
properties and what game can you forget
fight alongside goofy and donald and
like mickey is this like benevolent
Arthurian king of the universe like it's
too good so now that they've embraced it
they announced that the ultimate unlock
for Disney infinity 3.0 a weapon so you
can play with Keyblade and then there's
that exclusive Mickey costume coming out
oh no it was exclusive to d23 only five
thousand were made I got one I'm so
excited um but then Kingdom Hearts 3
they they didn't show any footage but
just the announcement itself of coming
out on stage and saying kingdom hearts 3
is going to feature a world from big
hero 6 the crowd went nuts and then they
showed a piece of concept art which is
I'm don't want to spoil big hero 6 so
I'm not going to say anything about it
because as they explained the events of
the world the big hero 6 world in
kingdom hearts are taking place post the
film oh okay which is interesting
because most Kingdom Hearts worlds in
previous games you us Sora or whoever
you are playing as enters the world and
the world state is within the realm of
the movie so for example you enter the
Cinderella world and you are it's an
escort mission together the get her to
the ball it's like it's the stuff like
that so it's odd seeing that they're
doing a post movie world stay and I
wonder if if that's what Kingdom art is
going to be it's like everything is
settled and now we're sort
picking up the pieces of everything that
is that has fallen into place if that's
if they're really wrapping that in that
way I'm not like okay well I hope you're
gonna say the same thing as me but I was
like Enter the Matrix came to mind we're
like imagine if we use this maybe not
the most flattering comparison but if
they use this as like a through-line to
a sequel to big hero 6 what are you
thinking no no I was also going to say
like you mentioned picking up the pieces
of a shattered world which is also what
kingdom hearts is yet with all literally
terrible games like Oh birth by Sleep
256 no no no birth by sleep was great in
order of best games it's kingdom hearts
2 birth by sleep literally everything
else with kingdom hearts 3d at the
bottom cuz that game was garbage do we
know what other worlds gonna be kingdom
hearts 2 what a dns over the past like
since they talked about they announced
tangled at e3 and Hercules was revealed
through a weapon wash it says a bit
irrelevant anymore yeah her keys ever
feel is that even relevant just Hercules
all the lion king is like you kids today
is not gonna have Cinderella they have
the mainstays Little Mermaid Hades is
Hades is a very funny charismatic
villain and I have to imagine that they
keep him around for doing stuff like
that you got a good characters good
stuff the Hercules world has been in
every kingdom hearts game to date you
fight in the calcium you do whatever so
I'm assuming that that's gonna be there
tangled I'm hoping I know that they've
said that they're not going to do frozen
but they'd be dumb to not include frozen
would they do Star Wars so I have heard
things from different people and because
Star Wars and Marvel will start with I i
heard that star was in Marvel Marvel are
not true Disney properties so they might
not use them however big hero 6 is a
marvel property I think at this point
not including a Star Wars world would be
totally foolish I just want to see
Mickey Mouse come out the friggin
lightsaber the lightsaber keyblade or
whatever it doesn't mean he pees head
off that's what we all want to see no
good make it happen busy watch what is
happening over at Disney Interactive
because like between everything they've
done with the toys to life stuff between
like opening up thing as I kingdom
hearts I think about what happened with
like the Grim Fandango remake we're like
they couldn't do that with Lucas and
then suddenly like it's happening like
suddenly Double Fine have like the
rights that they just allowed them to do
it like there's a big shift happening in
their games department the past couple
years and that shift is
how can we make money oh yeah no it's
definitely definitely revenue driven but
it's there they're embracing all of the
like by taking in Star Wars and taking
in Marvel and sort of acknowledging the
kingdom hearts is this big thing I think
Disney is saying hey we're listening to
you we know you want this stuff so we're
going to like give it to you and we're
going to support it their Kingdom Hearts
announcement they had baymax come out on
stage like the door was too small so he
like squished out and he like did the
pound thing with the president of Square
Enix and they're standing on stage and
it's like they're talking about how
they're there they're so excited to be
working with it working on the game and
everything and I think Disney is really
embracing that interactive element like
we've got battlefront and we have the
battle pod which is the thing and disney
infinity they are pouring so much
resources into did so many researchers
into disney infinity yeah i'm so excited
we've talked a lot about disney yeah so
we'll leave it at that thank you so much
Lex very courageous thank you and more
Disney news right here huh case both
calm yeah but for a moment we got to
take a little bit of a break I didn't
even know Mary put this on the running
order ID no [ __ ] idea apparently
they've dug up Gary Jules and doesn't do
my I don't know whatever I'm the go
Jules who knows and there's a new serum
you know I'm talking about you I could
dug up Gary do you guys got you to look
up get mad world Gears of War ring a
bell here it is an HD or 1080 60 I don't
know
around me are familiar faces worn out
places worn out faces had my head I
wanna drown my sorrow no tomorrow no
tomorrow and I find it kind of funny
find it kind of sad the dreams in which
I'm dying are the best I've ever had
find it hard to tell you I find it hard
to take when people run in circles it's
a very very
get the xbox one bundle now 349 Rainbow
six siege has been delayed December
first 315 is the new release date the
same day as Just Cause 3 curiously
enough to and I've got Mike McCarty an
errand Sampson here to chat a little bit
about the disappointment of Rainbow six
siege being bumped a couple of months
also bad betas in general and I got a
lot of thoughts about yourself iron
first of all Mike add details on this
bad boy it's we pushed three months
surprised at all uh a little bit i mean
the mean the bay the good thing is the
beta is still what September to
mid-september yeah yeah the beta is
still the same date so you're still
gonna be able to get your hands on the
closed beta they've been throwing keys
away like nobody's business like you're
you're gonna be able to play this game
it does hasn't been delayed that much
like I splits come out in October it's
been pushed back to December it's not so
bad and it did she talk about the beta
because this is a game that like it has
been really been baited for like a year
now like it and there's been a couple of
them and I remember keep going back and
new stuff being out and being tweaked a
lot yeah I mean games go into beta is
for I mean when they go into beta is for
the right reason it's for balance that's
what they always claim when they delay
is will we get we need time to like
actually dig through our play tests and
fix the games there's a couple of games
it's interesting like a good case study
was battlefield hardline yes did too
many betas yeah Roy 33 when they nested
like I think that weekend yeah I had the
first beta and then they fundamentally
scrapped out almost an entire mode
they're just kind of rejigged everything
from there you think it had too many tho
thread it's like yeah like betas are
kind of an art form if you give away too
much of your game then when it launches
people might have already played your
game you know I mean some games like
even destiny when it originally launched
I think you'd played about a fifth of
the content yeah Roy yeah by the time it
launched because of the beta was on one
of those I don't like four or five
planets also you could argue with all
the changes they've made that this past
year has been a beta yeah sounds
interesting betas are something that
developers can use if they use them
right and they use their delays right
you end up with
better game if they use them wrong
you've already burned out your audience
before you launch your title I'm also
curious because didn't they kind of say
that the reason for the beta was to
largely work on the coop like the ex
Pacific co-op mode will already the
terrorist hunt yeah terrorist hunt was a
highly requested mode by the fans I I
think a lot of people who you know
played Vegas and some of the other
titles they like multiplayer not
everybody loves multiplayer just because
you know it's one life you get hit and
you're out you got to sit there and
watch it watch your friends finish every
match so having that co-op is important
because it lets you stay alive longer do
more with your friends we played it at
e3 and it was actually very challenging
which I thought was cool like we played
on the higher level mode or the higher
difficulty modes and the AI was quite
good and your team communication had to
be good so a lot of the strategies were
the same so it's a more excessive
terrorist times like a more accessible
version of the multipolar which I'm
curious why that's our like having so
many field played siege already i'm
wondering why I pushed it back again I
wonder what actually was the impetus for
that final to say it was there because I
played a little bit of us Erin I know
you played a lot more are there any
standard sort of parts of Rainbow six
siege that you think required dressing
was there like a lack of modes like of
maps or was there was there like
gameplay stuff do you think actually
didn't need a lot of TLC one of the
things that they could get a little
handicapped on is the fact they only
showed 10 of their 20 classes right so
you know the maybe people got really
good with the first ten one of them you
know including pulse who could see
through walls he was a little
overpowered so they tweaked his ability
but then you know you're gonna launch
the game there's gonna be another ten
player and any of them could break the
game I mean you know they showed a medic
class recently who can fire revival
darts there's any number of things that
a new class member can do to mess with
the game so do you think like developers
are baby gunning a little bit gun-shy in
terms of releasing games that are like
imbalance like I was talking to the
overwatch guys at Gamescom and they've
basically used every event via blizzcon
or packs even III
and games calm as well as like ways of
basically like doing a be testing and
like you know alpha testing or beta
testing their game there do you think
like people are a little bit reticent of
releasing games that are is like
perfectly polished me balanced yeah
especially in light of the last couple
years especially with so many games you
could name I can name like three off the
top my head I had pretty poor release
states you know like there's battlefield
hardline like you mentioned then there's
a Sanskrit unity which isn't as
multiplayer focused but it's kind of if
they're up front about it and say
there's gonna be a beta this is our
release I'm I'm fine with what Ubisoft
doing with a siege just because I mean
again if it's it's not that much of a
delay but it's still a delay but if it's
not gonna be like another four months
like at least is this calendar year yeah
Yves give on came out i think it was
around III saying like this was going to
be the biggest FPS you would be soft
have ever made yeah they wanted to add
so far cry 4 they're obviously like
wanting this to be like a big esportiu
like a G like a chemist right go level
kind of of people playing it you always
have to be a little careful though as a
journalist when it comes to those sorts
of ambitious statements that's the kind
of thing that your audience will tell
you if you have if you're telling your
audience that's what it's gonna be that
may or may not happen does it feel like
that to you you're someone who plays
massive amounts of like online
first-person shooters it's specifically
like military tactical ones does it CH
feel like that type of breakthrough game
Rainbow six siege I I personally love
the tactical combat I like the change of
pace but it's gonna have to prove that
it's not like evolved which was really
good at doing one thing but ended up a
lot of people felt just being a
one-trick pony and if you didn't like
that pony like then the game had nothing
for ya right it turns out after it
seemed like anyway in the months after
involves release that not enough people
did like that pony in the fall off was
like that hurts the game so much more
when there's not a lot of people playing
out like you need that critical mass
right so yes you're just gonna have to
prove that it's a more versatile game if
they want it to be competitive with far
cry I mean you know you're not going to
be popping a wingsuit and like flying
200 feet down a canyon and then stabbing
an elephant to death with you know
shovel unless that ever gonna happen and
what they delayed it for yeah yeah i
guess i'll have to wait and find out
iron I'm like thank you so much come on
talking all about rainbow six
each which would be out like I said
first day of December right before
Christmas and that is if you're not
playing just cause 3 that day as we're
going to be back in a second talking
about call of duty black ops 3 I think I
tweeted it was black ops 2 earlier
accidentally there's so many call of
duty games to have brought two point two
point five well the beta right now is
ever the same because all the beta two
people in my early snip from a hearty I
will be back in a second oh first of all
any snip I don't even think that's the
thing tell us in the borderlands got a
new trailer for that bad boy rated M for
Mature
so where's the last piece little one
it's there
I can't think of a better crew than a
pair of Pandoran con artists and a
Hyperion stooge to figure out a way to
get it for me you don't get that beacon
you're all as good as dead let's get to
work
give me one reason why you think we
could possibly break in you think old
Jack would leave his meat buddy hanging
but say we shared the power I had when I
sat in this room what would you do with
it
you ready for this I was wired ready
it's that time of year again folks call
the duty season like me Hardy and Aaron
Sampson here to tell us all about the
black ops 3 beta which we got a kind of
a like 24 hours early access on I know
48 maybe 48 Eric Tejano spent last night
basically leveling up to on yeah all
night when he got to level 28 was it
yeah we're not sure if that's the cap
yet but that's like the soft cast his
cap yeah he was his goal was to unlock
the killer bee swarm okay you got that
which he did yeah yes killer bees will
talk about killer bees in just a second
who doesn't like talking about that
first of all Mike the specialist this is
a sort of a new aspect of the series and
tell us about the characters that you
played how you sort of how you unlock
them and how they work in the game sure
yeah I think this is one of the major
additions if not the major edition of
black ops 3 so they're essentially these
these characters I mean they affect how
you look but that's minor but they also
each of them has these two abilities and
one is usually a weapon of some sort and
the second one's more of a tactical
ability kind of so you pick so piggy
pick ruin or a lot of people have been
using at the outrider because you start
off with four in the beta then you can
unlock two more at least but there's
ruin their very their superpowers are
kind of like destiny abilities so they
have yet ruined the first one you can
use he has this um like gravity spikes
jumping ground pound attack on a smash
titan smash life yeah there's the
seraphs which you is the fifth unlock in
the beta and she has like the hunters
golden gun which is just one hit kills
that was one of my favorites it was like
a revolver you know that not the highest
fire rate but it was one hit kill so if
you're accurate enough and then you know
the outrider has the sparrow longbow
which is just explosive arrows but they
also have those secondary abilities
which the outrider has this division
vision your vision pulse and it just for
like three seconds will highlight
through walls anybody in the area which
way they're facing it's kind of like
what the spectator mode looks like if
you're not playing but probably the most
interesting ones so far those profits
glitch yeah that one's awesome and Rob
got really good at which you pop the
ability and it rewinds you
or last couple of moves okay so you can
run into we're still trying to like wrap
her head around this thing but like you
could run into a room drop a grenade and
then teleport backwards out of the room
this sounds like a lot like like I know
it's the same company now but racer from
overwatch yeah does the same thing we
were able to like backtrack the whole
way yeah so at one point when i was
using it i was up kind of this elevated
roof i sprinted down someone came around
a corner i used it and i ended up back
on the roof and then snipe them what
actually really happened is i missed and
someone else kill me but i like to
imagine i snipe them but um and then rob
was around a corner I was right behind
him when we were playing on the same
team someone was shooting at him he used
it to go back to everywhere and I kind
of killed the person sorry so every once
in a while that creates some pretty
awesome like holy [ __ ] moments so it
worked really well but yeah the
specialist class in general these powers
you know they have like charge times and
there's certain perks that decrease
those charge times they really do affect
how you build your classes like what
weapons you use how you tailor it to
your play style so are you are you
always playing as a specialist it's not
basically you doing yes so you always
have at least one ability active you you
can only be one specialist at a time and
you can only have one of their options
active sorry years they also talked
about how certain modes even limit the
number of certain specialist right yeah
the giraffe specially to draft will it
be yeah like so yeah people can as of
now you can have like four outriders in
a match to ruins right later on in the
certain competitive matches if you take
that ability no one else can use it okay
interesting dota style picking out your
load add before before match it's it's
not in this but the stream that they did
had one more interesting mechanics I've
seen in a long time which was the band
protect system yeah where you can
actually vote in that to get rid of
something your opponent is using and you
text something that you're using so like
DotA's again kind of yeah yeah the
bonding system yeah that's weird and
that's what so when you're playing the
game do you at a distance know who your
fight like can you figure out who the
other specialists here by looking at
them because presumably knowing what
they can do is key to killing them right
exactly yeah so I don't know if people
notice a few times during this game play
the gun will just start you'll start
glowing red and that means that the
outrider just used their vision pulse
ability right so they know exactly where
you are so whenever I saw that I was
like
neither about to die but I'm going to
try to make a break for it because they
are always going to have the upper hand
on me when you know when prophet uses
glitch and goes backwards I kind of look
for where they came from to expecting
them to come through the same doorway
twice in a row so it's definitely just
as useful to know how other people are
going to use it as well as how you're
going to offensively use it which is a
cool dynamic as far as you know like
considering other people's moves as
opposed to your own hmm so it's really
interesting as far as those go a lot of
comparisons obviously to games like
titanfall and to destiny as well last
year with advanced warfare we saw a game
that was very much like titanfall in
terms of movement and whatnot perhaps
maybe even sort of more futuristic and
more variable than time for Aaron how
does this one field does it feel more
like advanced warfare just feel more
like a black ops games normal limb
movement system in this game is chasing
after titanfall more than advanced
warfare advanced warfare had I think
what Chris waters described as very
staccato movement yeah it's very jerky
some some people loved it some people
hated it this one it's got wall running
it doesn't do while running as well as
titanfall I'm always a big fan of if
you're gonna rip somebody off like do it
better than that you know like do it do
do something new or do something better
than the last guy in this case the wall
writing feels a little tact on there's
some very specific routes you can take
but they usually end in dead ends what
is this nonsense out that your health
storm right scorestreak yeah such as
hands out like but yeah he's praying
yourself or not to do with my hands on
ya you drop that arm laptops but yeah I
mean the wall running is it it's okay
it's the routes aren't as good as
titanfall titanfall you were learning as
long as you play titanfall you could
learn a new route yeah there was always
a route you didn't know this one a
couple rounds on a map you know the
routes the routes dead end and just drop
you on to the map at certain places one
of the things that we liked about 10
fall was the sort of how long he lives
were and how how well it wasn't just
like a like you said like it's short
time to kill what what's that this game
feel like in comparisons out do you have
longer lives the more like Call of Duty
the time to kill is marginally longer so
you're actually having gunfights in this
game which I like advanced you know
warfare
feel like you just come around a corner
your body would hit the ground before
you could even register you'd been hit
right and then you would respawn before
like you even knew what happened so it's
just this really weird like non gunfight
mechanic of whoever shot first this one
you do actually get into those strafing
gunfights and if you're both wall
running you have that titanfall moment
where you're both like trying to shoot
and then one of you makes a mistake and
just fall off the cliff yeah so there's
there's better moments in this one I
think because of the longer time to kill
yeah how long's the bit of running for
for people who preordered it it's
tomorrow Wednesday the 19th i think
until sunday the 23rd whatever sunday is
all weekend and you guys have been
playing obviously for sort of like a day
in some change iron first of all what's
what's your take on this this type of
game do did you play much advanced
warfare as I said ty began to pull you
back into call of duty or is it not
scratching message I think it's doing
more of what I'd like to see in call of
duty which is again just actually having
gunfights but that being said you know
anytime the camera pulls out and I see
the larger map we're playing in I just
want these maps to be bigger I mean like
just about three player in you just take
a chance just like I had a couple more
players and make your maps a little
bigger because they're small you
especially in team deathmatch you're
always contending with a spawn flip
which always means there's somebody
shooting you in the back like if you're
in the middle of the map I guarantee
you're gonna get shot in the back
because somebody's gonna spawn behind
you and if they had slightly larger Maps
they could probably avoid yeah maybe a
halo 5 Guardians will scratch that itch
for you and like it what do you feel
about it yeah I like what it's taking
from advanced warfare in terms of the
movement it definitely feels like a
blessed pared down version of that and
more you know obviously black ops
combined with titanfall just not doing
either to an extreme I think the
specialist being the major addition is
interesting enough to pull me back in
but after you play for about an hour it
still feels like Call of Duty again the
last eight we've played it's got me
hooked I won't lie and it's so hard to
like try and figure out have those
systems are working when you're playing
like the first two days of an online
shooter because like two weeks down the
road it's like a completely different
ball game yeah and so the fact that
there are so few people playing when we
were
playing it was kind of always team
deathmatch right as I was looking
forward to trying out hardcore mode to
see how different the weapon loadouts
would work and how different abilities
would work and you know like I don't
know that they're bringing hardpoint
back from advanced warfare yet but I'm
just interested to see how those
specialist abilities will not only
affect how I'm building classes but how
I'll build different classes for
different game modes as well cool Mike
and I thanks so much for coming on yeah
talking is all about they call of duty
black ops 3 is that later this year and
the beta is running up until sunday and
also if you're watching right now you
can win yourself a key to the beta give
them away hopefully on there it is a
just so certain yet for a chance to win
go to tinyurl com for it / card giveaway
really no one had card giveaway pen
that's amazing idiots cod giveaway go
there right now you can win a beta code
for the sony playstation gaming system
for and this is only for us people
because we hate Europe no time for Asia
and I don't think anyone's watching in
Africa so no it's cuz the keys are
American sorry and North American North
America no us only us only take that
Canada and so if you want in on that go
to town eurocom for it / cod giveaway
and do whatever things they ask the you
to do on the page and then you can win
how about that cool gonna go play some
call dude boys I probably will yeah well
you doing for the rest of your weekend
Thompson I gotta decide whether I want
to stay up really late again and fights
COAS cuz last night my team was dropped
by his taint around twelve-thirty his
tanks yeah headed his taint kitty we got
tainted by know us how was it I said you
have to actually pass his taint he gives
you his taint and then you have to pass
it around there you go yeah destiny give
me bungee just giving you the tame I
guys spent a hundred dollars on a game
you should probably give you the pain
otherwise very least FYI play destiny
you sounded super frustrated this
morning like you did four hours of it
there was like no safe point or
something yes gonna say a point and the
reset happened anyway so great yep so
you get to fight for an hour for a
chance to try and fight for another
three or four hours great so that I can
become legend
how do you do this and have children
this is incredible you're like a you're
like an oddity to me it's amazing it's
not easy and my wife doesn't really
accept an explanation like oh sorry
honey i came home at twelve-thirty
because of skol losses do the whole wake
up at 2am and then play until 6am and
don't know the difference and Mike what
are you up to for the rest of the week I
will probably play embargoed are lockups
as well as it's something coming out
next week I don't know if its embargo
but um I should probably know that but
uh bargoed games happening in the office
at the moment yeah [ __ ] annoying and
then volume new stealth game does not
embargo just came out nope black
Bethel's game oh it's a so it's ambar go
yet okay good we're good good game
awesome is it good as a review up yep is
it I wrote it what was what score did
you give it give it an eight and eight 8
10 8 spot we're back thanks for watching
that see you next week